I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。而我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们还是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室辣妈。
Hello. Hi there, everybody. All right. Today we're going to talk about counseling, which is season seven, episode two. But first, Ange, I feel like I want to share with our podcast listeners the morning that we had getting here. Okay. We had quite the text thread going this morning with Sam and Cassie, you and me. I've got a summer cold.
大家好。大家好，各位。好了。今天我们要聊的是“心理咨询”，也就是第七季第二集。但首先，安吉，我觉得我挺想跟我们的播客听众分享我们今天来这儿的早晨。好吧。今天早上我们跟山姆和卡茜，还有你和我，有个挺热闹的短信群聊。我得了夏季感冒。
I can't believe I am congested again. Like, I can't believe it. You just kicked it. I barely kicked it and now it's back. This is, you know, kids going to camps and I don't know, we're bringing all the stuff home. Jeremy McJerms. So this morning, y'all were checking in with me,
我真不敢相信我又鼻塞了。真的，我简直不敢相信。你才刚摆脱它。我才刚摆脱它，现在它又回来了。你知道的，这就像是孩子们去夏令营，然后，我不知道，我们把各种东西都带回家了。杰米·麦杰姆（Jeremy McJerms）。所以今天早上，你们都在向我确认，
you're like, Jenna, are you okay to record? And I was like, I'm gonna rally, I'm gonna do it. And then Sam was like. Yeah, I was like, I don't bring enough to this podcast, I'm gonna bring food poisoning. Aw, Sam. And you know, Cassie and I are looking pretty good this morning.
你们问，珍娜，你录音没问题吧？我就说，我会振作起来的，我能行。然后山姆就说。对，我说，我为这个播客贡献的还不够，我要把食物中毒也带上。哦，山姆。而且你知道，卡茜和我今天早上看起来气色相当不错。
Yeah, I don't appreciate that. We both just finished off a donut. Oh yeah, they have donuts in the lobby today. I want to point out Jenna's almost horizontal. She's almost reclined. She's pulled another chair next to her chair so she can recline. But listen to this. So after Sam and I are both like, we're going to do it, we're going to rally, we got it.
对，我可不这么觉得。我们俩刚吃完一个甜甜圈。哦对，他们今天在大厅里放了甜甜圈。我想指出的是，珍娜几乎是水平躺着的。她几乎是躺靠着的。她拉了另一把椅子在她的椅子旁边，这样她就能躺下了。但听着这个。所以在山姆和我双双表示，我们要上了，我们要振作起来，我们没问题之后，
I reached into my closet to grab my office lady's hoodie and I sliced my finger open on a broken edge of my plastic hanger. So then I'm like, you know what, it's still okay. I'm still going in. So I'm driving in to work and driving my daughter to camp first. And there was this big sort of that moment where someone cut in front of the line of cars that were headed toward this one exit. Everything slowed down and I had to slam on the brakes.
我把手伸进衣橱去拿我的办公室辣妈连帽衫，结果我的手指被塑料衣架破损的边缘划破了。然后我想，你知道吗，没关系。我还是要去的。于是我开车去上班，先送我女儿去夏令营。结果发生了这么一件事，就是有人强行插进了一排开往这个出口的汽车队伍。所有车速都慢了下来，我不得不猛踩刹车。
But I could tell around me that like, there was not enough space for everybody. Oh, no. Did you get hit? Yeah. Did you hear the noise? You got hit? Did the brake noise before it, like, were you know what's coming? No, it wasn't that. I just could feel, like, the time and space around me. Oh, God. It slows down.
但我能感觉到周围的情况，就是大家的间距根本不够。噢，不。你被撞了吗？对。你听到声音了吗？你被撞了？刹车声之前，就是，你知道要发生什么了吗？不，不是那样的。我只是能感觉到，比如我周围的时间和空间。哦，天哪。变慢了。
And I said out loud to my daughter, I said, I think we're gonna be in an accident. And then the person behind us ran into us. It was a fender bender to call it an accident. It's not really an accident. And then of course it's LA. So I'm expecting this person is gonna take off. But I'm like, no way he's pulling over.
我大声对女儿说，我说，我觉得我们要出车祸了。然后我们后面的那个人就撞上了我们。这只是一次轻微的剐蹭，叫它车祸有点言过其实了。然后当然啦，这里是洛杉矶。所以我以为这人会直接逃逸。但我心想，才不会呢，他把车停下了。
He pulled over. He gets out of his car, young guy, so sweet he's wearing a Vote for Pedro t-shirt. Oh, Napoleon Dynamite fan. Yes, yes. We check my bumper, nothing to write home about, we're all going to be fine. But here's the kicker. Guess where he was going? To go to work. Where? The Wizarding World of Harry Potter. Oh, at Universal. Yes, which we had just been to a few days ago. And I got so excited. I was like, oh my gosh, he had just moved here from Hawaii. He had borrowed this car from the person he's living with to drive to his job at Wizarding World of Harry Potter. You know, they all talk in accents in the Wizarding World of Harry Potter. You know, they all talk in accents
他把车停下了。他从车里出来，是个年轻小伙，人真好，穿着一件“投票给佩德罗”的T恤。哦，《拿破仑 dynamite》的粉丝。对，对。我们检查了我的保险杠，没什么大不了的，我们都会没事的。但重头戏来了。你猜他要去哪儿？去上班。去哪儿？哈利·波特的魔法世界。哦，在环球影城。对，我们几天前才刚去过。我当时太兴奋了。我说，天哪，他刚从夏威夷搬来。他借了合租室友的车，去他在哈利·波特魔法世界的的工作岗位。你知道的，在哈利·波特魔法世界里大家说话都带着口音。你知道的，大家说话都带着口音
in the Wizarding World of Harry Potter. It's very theatrical, the whole experience. And I said to him, do they make you speak in accents? And he said, no, if you have an accent, you can speak in it. But he said he does it anyway, because he's an aspiring actor, and he likes to do voice work. We had a lovely chat on the side of the road and now here I am.
在哈利·波特魔法世界里。整个体验非常有戏剧性。我问他，他们逼你们说口音吗？他说，不，如果你本来就有口音，你就可以用。但他还是坚持这么做，因为他是个有抱负的演员，而且他喜欢做配音工作。我们在路边愉快地聊了一会儿，现在我到这儿了。
And he's in the lobby and he's gonna, no I'm kidding. I love the idea that he bumped into Pam from the office and you were excited about his job. I was, I was like tell me everything. No, he did end up recognizing me and I took a photo with him. So if you know this guy and he tags us, I'll try to find it. I'll repost it.
然后他在大厅里，他要，不，我开玩笑的。我喜欢这个想法，他撞上了《办公室》里的帕姆，而你对他的工作感到很兴奋。我是啊，我当时就说，把一切都告诉我。不，他最后确实认出我来了，我和他合了张影。所以如果你认识这个人，而且他给我们打了标签，我会试着找找看。我会重新发布它的。
I love that you were just chatting him up on the side of the road because I would have been there for all of that and then I would have been like, what are you doing today? I know. I was like, well, I should probably go. I have to go to work. I have to drop my daughter off at camp. Exactly. But we're all fine and we're here. I think I'm maybe good for the day.
我喜欢你在路边跟他闲聊的样子，因为如果是我，我会经历这一切，然后我会说，你今天打算做什么？我知道。我当时想，嗯，我大概得走了。我得去上班。我得送女儿去夏令营。没错。但我们都很好，而且我们在这儿。我想我今天大概没问题了。
You're good. I don't know. Knock on wood. Knock on wood. All right, that was my morning tangent. Should we get started? Let's do it. This episode of Counseling was written by BJ Novak
你很好。不知道。敲木头。敲木头。好啦，这就是我早晨的题外话。我们开始吧？开始吧。这一集的“心理咨询”由BJ·诺瓦克编剧
and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. And here's your summary. As a punishment for spanking Luke in front of the entire office, Michael must complete six hour-long counseling sessions with Toby. Dwight seeks a pretty woman-style revenge on a salesman who snubbed him at the Steamtown mall,
由杰弗里·布里茨执导。以下是剧情摘要。作为在整个办公室面前打卢克屁股的惩罚，迈克尔必须和托比完成六次为期一小时的咨询。德怀特对一个在斯廷镇购物中心冷落他的推销员展开了《风月俏佳人》式的报复，
and Pam scamps her way into a new job title. I mean, in this episode, I was like, Pam, who are you? You know, when this happened, it was sort of like one of those controversial character moments. We got a lot of messages about it, and we also got mail.
而帕姆则靠着厚脸皮混得了一个新职位。我是说，在这集里，我心想，帕姆，你是谁？你知道，当这件事发生时，这有点像是那种引发争议的角色时刻。我们收到了很多关于它的信息，我们还收到了信件。
I'll read it later. Okay. All right. Fast fact number one. I mentioned that Michael has to do these counseling sessions with Toby. That's our A storyline. It's revealed at two minutes and 52 seconds that Toby has a degree in social work from Temple University.
我待会儿再读。好吧。好吧，趣事一号。我提到迈克尔必须和托比进行这些心理咨询。这是我们的主线剧情。在2分52秒时透露，托比拥有天普大学的社会工作学位。
I took a picture of it. He's standing so proudly by it and then it goes wonky. Yes. Well, the shot is only two seconds long, but a lot went into getting that diploma because it is a real diploma. From the actual university. We got a letter from Raymond Betzner in Williamsburg, Virginia that says this, I was the Associate Vice President for Marketing and Communications at Temple University in
我拍了张照片。他站在它旁边显得十分自豪，然后镜头就变得扭曲了。是的。好吧，这个镜头只有两秒钟，但为了弄到那个毕业证花了不少心思，因为它是一张真正的毕业证。来自真正的大学。我们收到了来自弗吉尼亚州威廉斯堡的雷蒙德·贝茨纳的一封信，信上写道，我在2010年
2010 and helped get Toby his degree. The degree is real. How can Toby be a graduate from Temple University? Oh, well, lady, we got a bunch of mail about, like, when was this happening? Was this before or after he was in the seminary? Was it before or after he worked in advertising? Toby's backstory is much like Andy's. It's just a freefall.
担任天普大学的市场营销与传播副校长，并帮助托比拿到了他的学位。这个学位是真的。托比怎么会是天普大学的毕业生呢？哦，好吧，女士们，我们收到了一堆关于这事的信，比如，这到底是什么时候发生的？这是在他进神学院之前还是之后？这是在他从事广告工作之前还是之后？托比的背景故事和安迪的很像。简直就是自由落体。
It is. Raymond went on to say, I got an email one day from a member of the office staff. I'm retired now and no longer have access to my emails, so I can't tell you who exactly it was. I was told they wanted Toby to have a master's in social work from Temple University and could I make it happen? And naturally, they needed it fast. Raymond goes on to say, If you know anything about higher education, you need to know two things. First, we take degrees and diplomas very seriously. And second, higher education doesn't move quickly.
确实是。雷蒙德接着说，有一天我收到了一封来自办公室员工的邮件。我现在退休了，已经无法访问我的电子邮件了，所以我不能告诉你具体是谁。我被告知他们希望托比拥有天普大学的社会工作硕士学位，我能搞定它吗？理所当然地，他们需要得很快。雷蒙德接着说，如果你对高等教育有所了解，你需要知道两件事。首先，我们非常重视学位和文凭。其次，高等教育的办事效率可不快。
But I was a fan of the show. I thought it was worth a shot. It took calls to the university registrar, the university council, and the conjoining of several others to clear the path for this to happen. Along the way I kept getting nervous calls from folks at the office because they needed it soon. I was trying. Oh my gosh. Then Raymond says, I will also admit that I tried to get a little something in return for all this effort. Oh Raymond. I wanted to know if Michael and Holly got together before Steve Carell leaves the show. Raymond! Did they tell him? No. He says the staff at the office aren't dumb and they didn't let anything out in advance.
但我一直是这部剧的粉丝。我觉得可以一试。这需要给大学教务长、大学委员会以及其他好几个人打电话，为这件事扫清障碍。这一路上我不断接到办公室里人们打来的紧张电话，因为他们急需。我当时在努力。天哪。然后雷蒙德说，我也得承认，我曾试图为这一切努力捞回一点回报。哦，雷蒙德。我想知道在史蒂夫·卡瑞尔离开剧组之前，迈克尔和霍莉是否在一起了。雷蒙德！他们告诉他了吗？没有。他说办公室的工作人员并不傻，他们没有提前透露任何消息。
I love that what he wanted was scoop on storylines. Exactly, not a set visit, not like an autographed something. Tell me about Holly and Michael. He needed to know. He said, I'm pleased to say we were able to get the diploma approved and printed and set to California. The photo of Toby pointing to his Temple University School of Social Work diploma was hot on Temple University's social media for weeks.
我喜欢他想要的竟然是剧情内幕。没错，不是片场参观，也不是什么亲笔签名。告诉我关于霍莉和迈克尔的事。他迫切想知道。他说，我很高兴地宣布，我们成功让文凭获得批准并打印出来，寄给了加州。托比指着他的天普大学社会工作学院文凭的照片在天普大学的社交媒体上火了好几个星期。
Aw. So I reached out to Randy Cordray about this, Angela, and he said that the writers had originally considered Wake Forest University for Toby. But when they inquired about getting a degree in social work, they found out that Wake Forest does not offer a degree in social work, they found out that Wake Forest does not offer a degree in social work, just sociology. So that's when the writers pivoted a temple.
哦。所以我为此联系了兰迪·科德雷，安吉拉，他说编剧们最初为托比考虑的是维克森林大学。但当他们打听社会工作学位时，他们发现维克森林大学不提供社会工作学位，他们发现维克森林大学不提供社会工作学位，只有社会学。所以编剧们这才把目标转向了天普大学。
And James Carey solved the mystery for Raymond. It was Phil Shea who reached out to him. Phil Shea sent him a prepaid FedEx envelope to send back two diplomas, and in return, he did send Raymond two Dunder Mifflin hats. Aww. So Raymond, do you still have your Dunder Mifflin hat? Email us a photo of you with your hat. Please, Raymond, can we put you in Office Lady's stories?
而詹姆斯·凯瑞为雷蒙德解开了这个谜团。是菲尔·谢伊联系了他。菲尔·谢伊寄给他一个预付的联邦快递信封，让他寄回两份文凭，作为回报，他确实寄给雷蒙德两顶邓德米夫林帽子。哦。所以雷蒙德，你还留着你的邓德米夫林帽子吗？给我们发一张你戴着帽子的照片吧。求你了，雷蒙德，能让我们把你写进办公室辣妈的故事里吗？
We would love it. Well, I love knowing all of that. I mean, those little details always blow my mind. Same. All right, are you ready for fast fact number two? Yes. All right, this one is a little detail from Pam's storyline of trying to get her new job. We got a lot of mail from folks in Australia. Oh, yeah, because she talks about Canberra. Yes.
我们太乐意了。嗯，我喜欢了解所有这些。我是说，那些小细节总是让我大开眼界。我也是。好了，你们准备好听趣事二号了吗？准备好了。好的，这个小细节来自帕姆试图争取新工作的主线剧情。我们收到了很多来自澳大利亚粉丝的信。哦，是的，因为她提到了堪培拉。是的。
We got mail from Kimmy G in Canberra, Australia, who said, I grew up in the Barra. And this is just so random because Canberra is a tiny freezing often-missed city in Australia. Most people don't even realize that it is the Australian capital. And then she gave this fun fact. Let's hear the fun fact. The fun fact is when they were deciding where they should put the capital of Australia, they couldn't decide between Sydney or Melbourne. And it was a really heated debate. And they couldn't agree. So they literally built a whole new city in the middle of both of those cities.
我们收到了来自澳大利亚堪培拉的基米·G的来信，她说，我在“巴拉”长大。这太随性了，因为堪培拉是澳大利亚一个极小、极冷、经常被忽略的城市。大多数人甚至没有意识到它是澳大利亚的首都。然后她分享了一个有趣的冷知识。我们来听听这个有趣的冷知识。这个有趣的冷知识是，当他们决定把澳大利亚首都在哪儿时，他们在悉尼和墨尔本之间做不出决定。这是一场非常激烈的争论。他们无法达成一致。所以他们索性在两座城市的中间凭空建了一座新城市。
Just to make it the capital? Yes. Isn't that amazing? Yeah. Well, Kimmy G got me curious about Canberra and I started looking up details about the city. It looks very cool. But the thing that really stood out to me is that there are all of these rumors, I guess, or stories, scuttlebutt, lore, Canberra lore, maybe urban legends, that there are these
就为了把它做成首都？是的。这不是很神奇吗？是的。嗯，基米·G让我对堪培拉产生了好奇，我开始查阅关于这座城市的细节。它看起来非常酷。但真正让我印象深刻的是，有各种各样的传言，我猜，或者故事、闲话、传说、堪培拉传说，也许是都市传说，说这里有
secret underground tunnels throughout the whole city. And I guess the rumors are that these tunnels have been used for like international espionage. Oh, super sleuthing? Yes. Sleuthing in Canberra? So I digged some more and I think most of the rumors have been debunked. But then I started to think that the debunking
贯穿整个城市的秘密地下隧道。我猜传闻说这些隧道曾被用于国际间谍活动之类的事情。哦，超级侦探活动？是的。在堪培拉搞侦探活动？所以我又深挖了一下，我觉得大部分传言都被揭穿了。但后来我开始觉得，这些辟谣
was part of a conspiracy to hide the tunnels. I went so deep on the tunnels. Here's what I've decided. Okay. Lady, when Mom Detectives is in its fifth season. We're going to Australia? Yes. We need an international episode.
其实是掩盖隧道阴谋的一部分。我对这些隧道研究得太深了。这是我得出的结论。好吧。女士们，当“妈妈侦探”拍到第五季的时候。我们要去澳大利亚吗？是的。我们需要一集国际篇。
We investigate the tunnels of Canberra. Oh my gosh, yes. Well, lady, I knew that Canberra was the nation's capital because one of my best friends ever, Micah, is from Canberra. Oh my gosh. Yes. I didn't know that. Does he know about the tunnels?
我们去调查堪培拉的隧道。天哪，是的。好吧，女士们，我知道堪培拉是国家首都，因为我最好的朋友之一，迈卡，就是堪培拉人。哦，天哪。是的。我不知道这个。他知道隧道的事吗？
I don't know. We can call him. Should we call him? Yes. Yes, we can get to the bottom of it right now. We're going to call friend, Michael Peters, also known as Micah. Let's see, let's give him a buzz.
我不知道。我们可以打电话给他。我们要给他打电话吗？对。是的，我们现在就能把事情弄个水落石出。我们要给朋友迈克尔·彼得斯打电话，也就是大家熟知的迈卡。来看看，我们给他打个电话。
Hi. Hey, Micah, we're calling you from the podcast. It's Angela and Jenna. Hi. Hi, how are you? We have a random question for you about Canberra, your hometown. Yes. Here is what I need to know.
喂。嘿，迈卡，我们在播客里给你打电话呢。我是安吉拉和珍娜。嗨。嗨，你们好吗？我们有个关于你的家乡堪培拉的随机问题想问你。好的。这是我需要知道的。
Is it true that there's an elaborate tunnel system underneath the city that is used for espionage? Have you heard this rumor? That I do not know. I heard that there were tunnels underneath the Parliament House, because you know, the whole government sits in Canberra. I don't know about secret spy tunnels. So I was able to confirm that there are little tunnels under the Parliament House. But I read this rumor that their secret passageways go all the way under Lake Burley Griffin. Wow, that's very cool. I did not know that though.
传闻说城市下面有一个复杂的隧道系统，被用来进行间谍活动，这是真的吗？你听过这个传言吗？这个我倒不知道。我听说议会大厦下面有隧道，因为你知道的，整个政府都在堪培拉办公。至于秘密间谍隧道，我可没听说过。所以我确实证实了议会大厦下面有一些小隧道。但我读到一个传言，说这些秘密通道一直延伸到了伯利·格里芬湖的下方。哇，那太酷了。不过我倒不知道这个。
You want to tell them what you told me last night, what Canberra is known for? Two things you said. Well, Canberra is, you know, the capital of Australia. It's like Australia's DC. And it's also famous because it's where they make all the porn in Australia. It's the Van Nuys of Australia. And I'm pretty sure we're also the only state, because it's a territory like DC, the Australian capital territory, where you're allowed to have fireworks. Oh, how about that? Fireworks and porn. How about that?
你想告诉他们你昨晚跟我说的堪培拉以什么闻名吗？你说的两件事。嗯，堪培拉，你知道的，是澳大利亚的首都。它就像澳大利亚的华盛顿特区。它也很有名，因为那是澳大利亚所有色情片制作的地方。它是澳大利亚的凡尼斯。而且我很确定我们也是唯一一个州——因为它是个像华盛顿特区那样的领地，澳大利亚首都特区——允许燃放烟花的。哦，这怎么样？烟花和色情片。怎么样？
Yeah. And tunnels. And like legal prostitution too. Oh, well, Cambrath stepping it up. What about gambling? Can I gamble there? Yeah, there's a casino. Yep.
对。还有隧道。还有合法的卖淫活动。哦，好吧，堪培拉真是在不断升级啊。赌博呢？我在那儿能赌博吗？对，有个赌场。是的。
Wow. But I think you can do that in other states too. It's not like in the US. I see. I see. All right, Micah, thank you so much for being our 411 call about Canberra. Yes, our Canberra expert. All right, love you.
哇。不过我想你在其他州也能做到这一点。不像在美国。我明白了。我明白了。好吧，迈卡，非常感谢你成为我们关于堪培拉的“百事通”热线。是的，我们的堪培拉专家。好的，爱你们。
Okay, love you guys. Bye. Bye. Well, we learned a lot of things we didn't think we were gonna learn about Canberra. Yes, we still are unsure about the tunnels, but I'll tell you what, this episode of Mom Detectives just got more fun. Just got real interesting. I mean, there's a lot that the Mom Detectives are going to see when we go there.
好的，爱你们哦。拜拜。拜拜。好吧，我们了解了很多原以为不会了解到的关于堪培拉的事情。是的，我们对隧道还是不太确定，但我跟你说，这集的“妈妈侦探”变得更有趣了。变得真的很有意思了。我是说，“妈妈侦探”们等我们去那儿的时候会有很多见闻的。
They're going to stumble across. Wowzer. All right, thank you, Micah. Yeah. Let's move to fast fact number three. It's just a little location breakdown. Our final storyline of this episode is going to have Dwight going to the Steamtown Mall. We went to the Burbank Town Center Mall to shoot this.
她们会无意间发现的。哇塞。好吧，谢谢你，迈卡。不客气。我们转到趣事三号。这只是一个关于外景的小梳理。我们这一集的最后一条主线剧情是德怀特要去斯廷镇购物中心。我们去伯班克购物中心拍的这个。
And that precious heirloom store, that was created from scratch by our set decorating crew headed by Steve Rostein. They used an empty store space on the second floor. And Randy shared with me that the original outline for this episode, like it never even made it into a script, originally had some scenes on a food court. And so, you know, they start prepping the episode long before we shoot it. So our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, actually had to find an empty store that we could dress that was also next to a food court.
而那个珍贵的传家宝店，是由史蒂夫·罗斯坦领导的布景装饰团队从零开始打造的。他们使用了二楼的一个空置店面空间。兰迪跟我分享说，这集最初的大纲——甚至都没能写进剧本里——原本在美食广场有一些场景。所以，你知道的，我们在拍摄前很久就开始筹备这一集了。所以我们的外景经理凯尔·克斯坦德实际上不得不寻找一个我们可以布置的空店铺，而且它还要紧挨着美食广场。
And he did it. We never used the food court, but pretty amazing. I mean, just another example of how they have to like always be ready. Yeah. And then maybe we didn't even need it. They always hustled. But lady, that's all I got. Those are my fast facts.
而他做到了。我们从来没用过那个美食广场，但真的很神奇。我是说，这只是他们如何必须时刻准备着的一个例子。对。然后也许我们甚至都不需要它。他们总是雷厉风行。不过女士们，我只有这些了。这就是我的趣事。
Well, before we get into this episode, I have a little something. Yes? I wanted to share something from one of our office ladies listeners. A lot of you might have heard of Elise Myers, and if you don't, go find her on Instagram or on the Tickety Talk, as I call it. I'm following Elise on Instagram, and I love her. She is a delight and brings absolute joy to the world. Yeah, and she's hilarious.
嗯，在我们进入这一集之前，我有个小东西要分享。是吗？我想分享一位办公室辣妈听众的内容。你们很多人可能听说过爱丽丝·迈尔斯，如果没有的话，去Instagram上或者像我所说的“嘀嗒”上找她吧。我在Instagram上关注了爱丽丝，我超爱她。她太逗了，给世界带来了绝对的欢乐。是的，而且她超级搞笑。
I mean, two words, Taco Bell, if you know, you know. That one went viral. But you guys, she's also a fantastic singer. And when I jokingly said on the podcast, can someone write a Whispers in the Break Room song when we were talking about cover up, she did it. It's awesome. And you got to hear it.
我是说，两个词，塔可钟，懂的都懂。那个火遍全网了。但你们知道吗，她还是个非常棒的歌手。当我在播客里开玩笑说，当我们谈到掩盖时，谁能写一首《休息室里的低语》这首歌，她真的写了。太棒了。你们一定要听听。
I overheard that Kelly's Birkin bag is actually fake and that Michael can't remember his own middle name and that Andy is always two hours late These are the whispers in the break room. I Heard that Meredith turned her desk into a mini bar and that Stanley schedules meetings and just sits in his car And there Ryan didn't graduate with a master's degree at least that's what I heard, but you didn't hear it from me. These are the whispers in the break room. If you want to know what's going on
我无意中听到凯莉的伯金包其实是假的，迈克尔甚至记不清自己的中间名，安迪总是迟到两个小时……这些都是休息室里的低语。我听说梅雷迪思把她的办公桌改造成了一个迷你酒吧，斯坦利安排了会议却只坐在自己的车里。还有，瑞安根本没有拿到硕士学位，至少我是这么听说的，但这可不是从我这儿听来的。这些的都是休息室里的低语。如果你想知道发生了什么
and you want it to come to you, the whispers in the break room. Just stick around long enough and learn a thing or two. And that was Whispers in the Break Room. Back to you, Angela and Jenna. Is that amazing? Amazing. I love it so much. When I saw that, you know, I follow her on Instagram.
又想让消息自己找上门来，听听休息室里的低语。只要在这儿多待一会儿，你就能学到一两招。这就是《休息室里的低语》。交给你了，安吉拉和珍娜。是不是很神奇？太神奇了。我太喜欢了。当我看到那个时，你知道的，我在Instagram上关注她。
And when I saw that, I was like, oh my God. And you texted me. It was like a simultaneous thing where we're like, oh my gosh, we're seeing this. Elise, I love so much about that song. It also kind of reminded me of when like Dolly Parton would harmonize with Emmylou Harris and Linda Ronstadt, but you're doing it all with yourself. It's like my brain doesn't even understand
当我看到那个时，我心想，哦，天哪。然后你给我发了信息。这就像是一个同步的时刻，我们俩都在说，哦，天哪，我们看到这个了。爱丽丝，我太喜欢这首歌的许多地方了。它也让我想起了当多莉·帕顿与埃米莉·哈里斯和琳达·罗恩斯塔特进行和声的时候，但你一个人把所有的都包办了。就像我的大脑甚至无法理解
how you do it and it's amazing. Thank you for letting us play that on Office Ladies, Elise. All right, on that delightful note, let's take a break because when we come back, Jim and Pam are late to work. ["The Time Is Now"] Well, we are back and Dwight is, he's shaming Jim and Pam because they're late again. But you know what? You know, because Jim had to open that bathroom door a while back.
你是怎么做到的，这太神奇了。谢谢你让我们在《办公室辣妈》里播放这首歌，爱丽丝。好了，在这个美妙的音符下，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，吉姆和帕姆上班迟到了。["The Time Is Now"] 好吧，我们回来了，德怀特正在训斥吉姆和帕姆，因为他们又迟到了。但你知道吗？你知道，因为吉姆前阵子不得不打开那个洗手间门。
Oh, they didn't get into the daycare that's close to Dundermifflin and now they have to drive all the way across town. Dwight sees an opportunity. He's like, hey, guess what? There is a daycare center right here in this very building. Dwight is going to give Jim and Pam a whole tour. Yes. The Sesame Avenue Daycare for Infants and Toddlers, where Mo's has apparently been painting in
哦，他们没能进那家靠近邓德米夫林的日托中心，现在他们不得不横穿整个城镇开车。德怀特看到了一个机会。他就像，嘿，你猜怎么着？在这个大楼里就有一家日托中心。德怀特要带吉姆和帕姆进行一次完整的参观。是的。为婴儿和幼儿开设的芝麻大街日托中心，据报道莫斯显然一直在一个胸前绑着卷心菜娃娃的黑暗房间里画画，
the dark with a Cabbage Patch doll strapped to his chest, is located in the former Michael Scott Paper Company. Well, Jenna, I thought I would break down the special features of the Sesame Avenue Day Care Center for Infants and Toddlers. According to Dwight, this is what your child's experience will include. A language skills and cognitive development area, which is just an eye chart on the old rusty shower. There is one blue bouncy ball on an otherwise empty wire shelf.
它就位于前迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的旧址。嗯，珍娜，我想我来梳理一下为婴儿和幼儿开设的芝麻大街日托中心的特色。根据德怀特的说法，你孩子的体验将包括以下内容。一个语言技能和认知发展区，其实就是挂在生锈旧淋浴头上的视力表。一个孤零零的、放在空空如去的铁丝架上的蓝色弹力球。
A magical toy box that has plastic forks and knives. And one soy sauce packet. He was very embarrassed by that. I know. He should be. He apologized. He should be. There are four metal buckets.
一个神奇的玩具箱，里面装着塑料叉子和刀子。还有一个酱油包。他对此感到非常尴尬。我知道。他理应如此。他道歉了。他理应如此。有四个金属桶。
One is a restroom. One is a feeding trough. One is a play bucket and one is for a possible plant. And for those of you who love a good background catch, if you go to 45 seconds, the Cabbage Patch doll strapped to Moses chest only has one red shoe on and the other foot just has a sock. Did you have Cabbage Patch kids when you were younger? Oh, I was overseas and I came stateside and everyone had one and I was like, I need this in my life. So yeah, I got one. What'd you name it? I don't remember. You don't remember? This was
一个是洗手间，一个是食槽，一个是玩具桶，还有一个是用来种植物的。对于那些喜欢寻找背景彩蛋的观众来说，如果你把视频拉到45秒，绑在莫斯胸前的那个卷心菜娃娃只穿着一只红鞋，另一只脚上只有一只袜子。你小时候玩过卷心菜娃娃吗？哦，我在海外，后来回到美国本土，每个人都有一个，然后我想，我的生活中需要这个。所以，对，我买了一个。你给它起名叫什么来着？我不记得了。你不记得了？这可是
such a big deal. I had two Cabbage Patch Kids and I remember their names so clearly. Christine Marie and Casey Alexander. Casey Alexander had curly auburn hair and Christine Marie had blonde ponytails. Mine had blonde hair with some freckles. I don't remember her name. You didn't love her. I didn't love her. Clearly. I got her late in the game, and she clearly didn't make a stamp on me.
一件大事。我有两个卷心菜娃娃，我把它们的名字记得清清楚楚。克里斯蒂娜·玛丽和凯西·亚历山大。凯西·亚历山大有着卷曲的红褐色头发，而克里斯蒂娜·玛丽梳着金色的马尾辫。我的娃娃有一头金发，还有一些雀斑。我不记得它的名字了。你并不爱它。我并不爱它。很显然。我入手得比较晚，而且它显然没在我身上留下什么深刻印象。
Oh, wow. You remember I was trying to get Mandy Moore to name her son Casey Alexander in honor of my Cabbage Patch Kid. Your Cabbage Patch Kid. I don't know why she didn't listen to you. Well, she has a second baby coming. Maybe she'll take my advice this time. Mandy, Casey Alexander, it's waiting for you.
哦，哇。你记得我曾试图让曼迪·摩尔给她的儿子取名为凯西·亚历山大，以此来纪念我的卷心菜娃娃。你的卷心菜娃娃。我不知道她为什么不听你的。好吧，她的第二个孩子要出生了。也许这次她会听取我的建议。曼迪，凯西·亚历山大，它正等着你呢。
Although, let's point out none of your children are named Casey Alexander. Well, listen, I had to ask Randy a question when I saw this cold open, Angela. I needed to know, did they have to clean out this room again? Because it was storage. Yeah. He said no. This is what he said, quote, we had finally gotten smarter and left the room empty and found a different place for post-production storage.
尽管让我们指出，你的孩子们没有一个叫凯西·亚历山大的。好吧，听着，当我看到这个片头开场时，安吉拉，我不得不问兰迪一个问题。我需要知道，他们得再次清理这个房间吗？因为它是储藏室。是的。他说没有。他是这么说的，原话是，“我们终于变聪明了，把房间空了出来，并在别处找到了后期制作的储藏室。”
He was just so fed up. He was like, fine. Randy also shared with me that Mike Schur, who plays Moe's, was insanely busy over at Parks and Rec, and that the writers of The Office would often try to put Moe's in an episode and then Randy would go check with Mike's schedule and then he wouldn't be able to do it and they would have to take Moe's out. This happened many times.
他实在是受够了。他当时想，好吧。兰迪还跟我分享说，饰演莫斯的迈克尔·舒尔在《公园与游憩》剧组忙得不可开交，《办公室》的编剧们经常试图把莫斯写进某一集里，然后兰迪就会去查看迈克的日程安排，结果发现他抽不开身，他们只好把莫斯删掉。这种情况发生过好多次。
So Randy said, finally, finally, Mike was like, yeah, my schedule is totally clear that day. I can come drop a cabbage patch to my chair. And everyone was so excited because we got to have Mo's back. Well, this episode opens with Toby and Michael sitting opposite one another in the break room. They're having a full on stare down. Michael looks like the Emperor, you know, in Star Wars when he's like giving that death look. No, I wouldn't know that because I haven't seen those films.
所以兰迪说，最后，终于，迈克说，好吧，我那一天的日程完全是空的。我可以来把一个卷心菜娃娃绑在我的椅子上。每个人都兴奋极了，因为我们终于能让莫斯回归了。好吧，这一集的开场是托比和迈克尔在休息室里相对而坐。他们正在进行一场激烈的对视。迈克尔看起来就像个皇帝，你知道的，在《星球大战》里那种露出死亡凝视的表情。不，我可不知道，因为我没看过那些电影。
I know you're thinking of Emperor Palpatine. Yes. Yes, thank you. Well, that's Michael in this opening scene. Thank you, Sam. I believe you. We had a fan catch from Zach K. from Acton, Ontario, Canada, who said, not really a question, but a comment.
我知道你想的是帕尔帕廷皇帝。对。是的，谢谢。好吧，开场这幕里的迈克尔就是这样。谢谢你，山姆。我相信你。我们收到了来自安大略省阿克顿市的扎克·K的粉丝留言，他说，其实不是一个问题，而是一个评论。
I love how this episode begins with 15 seconds, yes, I counted it, of silence before any dialogue. This must be a record for the longest silence in the show. Eh. What's the longest silence? 27 seconds of silence. Oh, with Jim and Pam. On the booze cruise.
我喜欢这一集以15秒的沉默——是的，我数过了——作为开场，中间没有任何对话。这绝对创造了这部剧中最长沉默时间的纪录。呃。最长的沉默是多久？27秒的沉默。哦，有吉姆和帕姆的。在酒轮游船上。
Oh my god, I was in it. I was in the longest. I'm like, what are you talking about? I wrote about it in a book. Welcome to my summer cold, everyone. But yes, I have to say, I thought it was a pretty bad ass move that the episode opens with so much silence. Well, I love how seriously Toby has taken this chance
哦，天哪，我参与了。我是那段最长沉默的亲历者。我心想，你在说什么呢？我在书里写过这个。欢迎来到我的夏季感冒，各位。不过是的，我必须说，我觉得这一集以这么长一段沉默开场，这招真是酷毙了。好吧，我喜欢托比如此认真地对待这次机会
to help Michael. He moves a small love seat. He puts a chair in there, a little coffee table. He has a plant, a box of Kleenex. He's going to get down to business and have therapy in the break room. We had some fan questions about this setup. The first one's from Nicole Q from Bowie, Maryland, who would like to know where did
来帮助迈克尔。他搬走了一个小双人沙发。他在那儿放了一把椅子，一张小茶几。他有一株植物，一盒面巾纸。他要动真格的了，要在休息室里进行心理治疗。我们收到了一些关于这个场景的粉丝提问。第一个来自马里兰州鲍伊市的妮可·Q，她想知道
Toby get these sofas from for the setup? They're in the annex in the little hallway. Oh, I was thinking they were from front reception. Because remember in the injury, Michael moves the couch from front reception into the conference room. I thought they were the ones that were in the annex, little lobby area. You're probably right. Closer. Closer. Not as big of a move. Thanks, Anne.
托比是从哪儿弄来这些沙发来布置这个场景的？它们就在附属建筑的小走廊里。哦，我还以为它们是前台那儿搬来的呢。因为记得在《受伤》那一集里，迈克尔把前台的沙发搬进了会议室。我还以为它们是附属建筑里那个小大厅区域的呢。你大概猜对了。更近。更近。不用搬那么远。谢谢，安。
You're welcome. Now we have a fan catch from Emily J. in Ohio, who has some comments about the little plant that you said Toby put on the table. What are the comments? Emily's theory is that the plant looks exactly like the one that died when Pam was on maternity leave and Emily thinks maybe Toby brought it back to life just to impress Pam. Emily!
不客气。现在我们收到来自俄亥俄州埃米莉·J的粉丝留言，她对你刚才说托比放在桌上的那株小植物有些评论。有什么评论？埃米莉的理论是，这株植物看起来跟帕姆休产假时死掉的那株一模一样，埃米莉觉得也许托比把它救活了，只是为了给帕姆留下深刻印象。埃米莉！
That is amazing. I sort of just thought Toby took Pam's plant. Pam, can I borrow this for today? Yeah, I wasn't sure because Pam has a different plant on her desk now. You know, the one with the bow. It looks almost like bamboo or something. So I don't know where this ivy plant came from. Well, Emily, it definitely looks like a Pam plant. I agree. Dwight is going to just burst into the bullpen telling everyone they must boycott Steamtown Mall, also the kiosk, cancel all your business with Steamtown Mall.
太神奇了。我之前只是觉得托比拿了帕姆的植物。帕姆，我今天能借用一下这个吗？对，我不确定，因为帕姆的桌上现在有了一株不同的植物。你知道的，带着蝴蝶结的那株。它看起来有点像竹子之类的。所以我不知道这株常春藤是从哪儿来的。好吧，埃米莉，它绝对看起来像是一株帕姆的植物。我同意。德怀特突然冲进办公区，告诉大家他们必须抵制斯廷镇购物中心，还有那个售货亭，取消所有与斯廷镇购物中心的业务往来。
And then Ryan has one of my favorite lines. Ryan says, America is one big mall. I loved that line, too. Did you know there's a mall outside of New York and you can go skiing in it? What? Yeah, and surfing. How do you ski in a mall? They have an indoor skiing thing.
然后瑞安说了一句我最喜欢的台词。瑞安说，整个美国就是一个大型购物中心。我也很喜欢那句台词。你知道纽约外面有个购物中心，你可以在里面滑雪吗？什么？对，还能冲浪。你怎么在购物中心里滑雪？他们有一个室内滑雪场。
My son found it because he loves skiing and he is trying to find a place to ski in the summer and he would like to ski in a mall in New York. If you go, will you please send me a picture? Of course! Please. I feel like there's a good chance we're going to end up skiing in this mall at some point in our lives. I'm so curious.
我儿子发现的，因为他喜欢滑雪，他正试图找个地方在夏天滑雪，他想去纽约的一个购物中心滑雪。如果你去了，能请你发张照片给我吗？当然！拜托。我觉得我们有很大的几率在生活中的某个时刻去这个购物中心滑雪。我太好奇了。
Jim wants to know, did something happen? Andy asks Dwight for context, but Dwight tells him you don't want to know. Yeah. Back in the therapy break room, Toby is really trying to connect with Michael, trying to get him to share about himself, and Michael is just saying a whole bunch of baloney to Toby, trying to get a rise out of him. This would have led to a series of talking heads where the bullpen shares their thoughts on Michael getting therapy.
吉姆想知道，发生什么事了吗？安迪问德怀特前因后果，但德怀特告诉他你不会想知道的。是的。回到治疗室里，托比真的在试图与迈克尔建立联系，试图让他分享自己的事情，而迈克尔只是对托比胡说八道，试图惹恼他。这本该引发一系列的单人采访，办公区的人们在其中分享他们对迈克尔接受心理治疗的看法。
Oh, please. In the episode, it starts with Phyllis. She says, I'm glad Michael is getting help. He has a lot of issues and he's stupid. This runner would have continued. Here are a few from the shooting draft. These were my shoots. See if you can guess who said which talking head. All right.
哦，拜托。在这一集里，是从菲利斯开始的。她说，我很高兴迈克尔在寻求帮助。他有很多问题，而且他很蠢。这个桥段本该继续下去。这里有几个来自拍摄初稿的台词。这些都是我的片段。看看你们能不能猜出哪个单人采访是谁说的。好吧。
First one up, Sam, Cass Kathy, Jenna, here we go. Michael isn't complex enough to need therapy. Can't someone just calmly explain to him what's wrong with him? Oh, Oscar? Yes. Very nice. All right. Next one.
第一个，山姆，卡茜，凯西，珍娜，我们来喽。迈克尔还不够复杂，不需要心理治疗。难道就没人能心平气和地跟他解释一下他哪里不对劲吗？哦，奥斯卡？是的。非常棒。好吧。下一个。
It is high time. High time. Angela? Is it you? Stanley! Okay. I think that line reading was just so good. Yeah.
是时候了。时候到了。安吉拉？是你吗？斯坦利！好的。我觉得那句台词的语气实在是太棒了。是的。
Okay. Angela does have one, and I thought rather than me reading it, let's just play it the way I said it on the day. Talking about how many feelings you have is a form of bragging. We get it. You have a lot of feelings. Whoop-de-doo. Wow. She's just so put out with everyone sharing their feelings. And Ryan has one that comes later in the episode. Oh, as the tag?
好的。安吉拉确实有一个，我想与其由我来读，不如我们直接播放我当时拍的那天的原声吧。谈论你有多少感受是一种炫耀的形式。我们知道了。你有很多感受。真了不起。哇。她对每个人都在分享自己的感受感到十分厌烦。瑞安在剧集后面也有一个。哦，作为尾声标签？
Mm-hmm. Yes. Well, we had a fan question from Sarah L. in San Antonio, Texas who said, I would love to know if there is a backstory as to why Michael hates Toby so much. I feel like Michael has such a blind affection for his employees that there must be something more to his hatred for Toby that explains it. Or is it just the classic angle of manager hates HR? I looked into this. And Michael has a line when he's meeting Holly for the first time. And he says that his job is to, quote, make the office fun, while HR's job is to make
嗯哼。是的。好吧，我们收到了来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市的莎拉·L的粉丝提问，她说，我很想知道，迈克尔为什么这么讨厌托比，这背后有什么背景故事吗？我觉得迈克尔对他的员工有一种盲目的喜爱，所以他对托比的憎恨背后一定有更深层的原因来解释。还是说这只是管理者讨厌HR的经典老梗？我查过这个。迈克尔在第一次遇到霍莉时有一句台词。他说他的工作是，引述原话，让办公室充满乐趣，而HR的工作是让
the office lame. So Toby's the fun stopper. Yes. And we kind of knew that. But then I found this amazing interview with Paul Lieberstein where he talks about this. How did they come up with, in the writer's room, this dynamic of Michael hating Toby so much? And he said that Michael's hatred of Toby
办公室变得无趣。所以托比就是那个扫兴的人。是的。我们之前差不多也知道了。但后来我找到了保罗·利伯斯坦的一段精彩采访，他在采访中谈到了这一点。在编剧室里，他们是怎么想出迈克尔如此憎恨托比这种动态关系的？他说迈克尔对托比的憎恨
goes back to a deleted scene from The Alliance. This is where they found this like true hatred of Toby goes back to a deleted scene from The Alliance. This is where they found this like true hatred of Toby. In the scene, Toby is coming in to sign Meredith's birthday card. And Paul said, I just go in, write something quickly and leave. That's the scene. But when they were shooting the scene,
要追溯到《同盟》中被删掉的一个片段。正是在那里，他们找到了这种对托比真正憎恨的根源。在那个镜头中，托比走进来在梅雷迪思的生日卡片上签名。保罗说，我只是走进去，迅速写点东西就离开。这就是那个镜头。但在拍摄这个镜头时，
I guess it took Paul a long time to physically write down what he was going to write down. I have a memory of this that he was writing in the card and it took a bit. Paul said, I could just feel him watching me and I could feel this hatred burning. And he said that Steve told him afterwards that it was in that moment that he decided as Michael to hate Toby. And then Paul said, it's really terrifying to act with Steve because he misses nothing. And that was when they ran with it, that Paul went to the writers and said, Michael hates Toby. Because you know if Jim took a long time to write a message,
我猜保罗花了好一会儿才真正把要写的东西写下来。我有这么个记忆，他在卡片上写字，花了一点时间。保罗说，我能感觉到他一直在看着我，我能感觉到那种憎恨在燃烧。他说史蒂夫事后告诉他，正是在那个时刻，他作为迈克尔决定开始讨厌托比。然后保罗说，和史蒂夫演对手戏真的很吓人，因为他什么都不会错过。也就是在那时，他们顺着这个思路演了下去，保罗去找编剧说，迈克尔讨厌托比。因为你知道，如果吉姆花很长时间写一条留言，
he would have all the patients in the world. Yeah. But Toby not really knowing what to write and taking a bit. Michael's like, ah. Yeah. Then of course that led to one of my favorite lines, I hate so much about the way you choose to be, which is what sums it all up. Yeah. We're about to start a whole new story arc for Pam. She's not having a great sales day.
他会有全世界所有的耐心。是的。但托比不知道该写什么而花了点时间。迈克尔就会想，啊。是的。然后这当然引出了我最讨厌的一句台词，我太讨厌你选择的生活方式了，这句话完美总结了一切。是的。我们要开始帕姆的一个全新故事线了。她的销售业绩不太好。
I know. She's just going to own that she sucks at it. She puts her head on her desk and Jim knows too. Yeah. We had a fan question from Cassandra P and Madison, Wisconsin, who said, this is one of my favorite Office episodes. And if I had an Angela-style note card to describe this episode, I would call it,
我知道。她只是大方承认自己不擅长这个。她把头埋在桌上，吉姆也心知肚明。是的。我们收到了来自威斯康星州麦迪逊市的卡桑德拉·P的粉丝提问，她说，这是我最喜欢的《办公室》单集之一。如果我要用一张安吉拉风格的便签来形容这一集，我会称之为，
Full Pam. Oh, I love it. Pam truly becomes the main character in this episode, and it sets her up for empowerment and strength for the rest of the series. Also, this season Pam's makeup is 100% on point. Go Pam. Oh, you look super cute. I know. Pam got really good with eyeliner. She did. I don't know what happened to her over the summer. Like we said, I got married over the summer, so I was just glowing. I think maybe that's part of it.
《全方位帕姆》。哦，我喜欢。帕姆在这集里真正成为了主角，这为她在整部剧接下来的走向中展现赋权和力量奠定了基础。另外，这一集帕姆的妆容可以说是100%在线。加油，帕姆。哦，你看上去超级可爱。我知道。帕姆的眼线画得越来越好了。确实。我不知道她夏天经历了什么。就像我们说的，我夏天结婚了，所以我当时整个人都在发光。我想也许这也是原因之一。
Happy person. What's up next, lady? Let's see. Oh, what's up next is John Krasinski breaking a lot. He is so tickled by Andy coming up to Dwight. It's saying, did you call my clients and use the F word? Yeah. There it is.
幸福的人。接下来是什么，女士们？让我想想。哦，接下来是约翰·卡拉辛斯基频频笑场。安迪走向德怀特时把他逗乐了。安迪说，你给我的客户打电话了，还用了F打头的脏话？对。就是那个。
Five minutes, 13 seconds. John is looking at Ed and it clearly starts breaking in the background. Well, we find out why Dwight wants to boycott the Steamtown Mall. It's because he went there with Moe's and he went to precious heirlooms and they wouldn't let him in. Yeah, he saw this amazing... Wizard holding a crystal. Yeah, he wanted this nice thing.
5分13秒。约翰看着埃德，背景里的他明显开始笑场了。嗯，我们找到了德怀特想要抵制斯廷镇购物中心的原因。因为他和莫斯去过那里，他去了那家珍贵传家宝店，而他们不让他进去。是的，他看到了这个惊人的……手里拿着水晶的巫师。是的，他想要这个好东西。
He so rarely treats himself to nice things. He made himself vulnerable. Yeah. He wanted it and they denied him entry. Kelly says, you need a pretty woman their asses. Everyone agrees. Well, except Creed who says they should start their own mall. I know. I love that line. Jim offers to go back to the store with Dwight to teach them a lesson.
他极少犒劳自己买好东西。他卸下了心防。是的。他想要它，而他们拒绝让他进去。凯莉说，你们得给他们来个《风月俏佳人》式的报复。大家都表示赞同。嗯，除了克里夫，他说他们应该自己开个购物中心。我知道。我太喜欢那句台词了。吉姆主动提出跟德怀特一起回那家店去给他们点颜色瞧瞧。
Andy's like, I'm coming too. This starts a hilarious storyline. Andy is going to start off with a talking head where he says, did you assume that I would automatically side with the rich snobby shop owner? He starts taking off his fancy cufflinks and throwing them, takes off his tie clip. There was a candy bag alt for Andy. Oh, please. Here's what it said. I love revenge. Well, not like violent revenge, not like kill bill, more like legally blonde.
安迪说，我也去。这就拉开了一条搞笑故事线的序幕。安迪将以一个单人采访开场，他说，你以为我会自动站在那个富有势利的店主那边吗？他开始解下自己华丽的袖扣并把它们扔掉，还摘下了领带夹。安迪有一个被删掉的糖果包镜头。哦，拜托。上面是这么写的。我喜欢复仇。嗯，不是那种暴力的复仇，不是像《杀死比尔》那样，更像是《律政俏佳人》。
Nobody's getting the top of their skull sliced off today. Thank you very much. Didn't sign up foronde. Nobody's getting the top of their skull sliced off today. Thank you very much. Didn't sign up for that. That's right. I love that Andy is a Legally Blonde fan. This leads in to my personal favorite talking head. It's Dwight. And Andy.
今天没有人会把头盖骨切成两半。非常感谢。没报名参加。今天没有人会把头盖骨切成两半。非常感谢。没报名参加那个。没错。我喜欢安迪是个《律政俏佳人》的粉丝。这直接引出了我个人最喜欢的单人采访。是德怀特。还有安迪。
And Jim. And then Kelly. Yes, and all they're trying to do is tell us the famous scene from Pretty Woman where Julia Roberts gets her revenge on the snooty shop owner. Mm-hmm. Big mistake.
还有吉姆。然后是凯莉。是的，他们都在试图重现《风月俏佳人》里的那个著名场景，朱莉娅·罗伯茨向势利店主复仇。嗯哼。大错特错。
Huge! That's right. Well, let's take a break, because when we get back, full Pam is happening. Sure is. She gets a real big idea. We're back! And a man enters the office looking for the office administrator. And Pam really perks up. Yes. Yes. Pam is like, that's me. I'm the office administrator.
大错特错！没错。好吧，我们休息一下，因为当我们回来时，《全方位帕姆》就要上演了。确实如此。她有个非常棒的主意。我们回来了！一个男人走进办公室寻找办公室行政人员。帕姆顿时精神一振。是的。是的。帕姆心想，那就是我。我就是办公室行政人员。
And we are not interested. We don't want your blinds, your window treatments. At eight minutes, 40 seconds, I'm busted. Who's busted? I'm busted. What are you busted for? I'm playing solitaire. On your computer?
我们不感兴趣。我们不需要你的百叶窗，不需要你的窗饰。在8分40秒时，我露馅了。谁露馅了？我露馅了。你因为什么露馅了？我在玩纸牌。在你的电脑上？
Yes, Angela Martin would never. Wow, that's very out of character. You should definitely have a spreadsheet on your computer. I know. Well, I want you to know that we have a guest star in the house. Let's hear it. Vincent Angelo, who plays the salesperson, has been on Desperate Housewives, Grey's Anatomy, Parks and Recreation, and House. It's my new favorite. I don't know
是的，安吉拉·马丁绝不会这么干。哇，这太不符合她的性格了。你的电脑上绝对应该有个电子表格。我知道。嗯，我想让你们知道，我们今天来了一位客座明星。让我们听听是谁。饰演推销员的文森特·安杰洛曾出演过《绝望的主妇》、《实习医生格蕾》、《公园与游憩》和《豪斯医生》。这是我的新最爱。我不知道
what I like more, discovering someone has been on Monk or House. You just like seeing a guest star in the House. I know. When they've been on House. Become my favorite. I also like tracking if people have played more than one character on Law and Order. I love the big pause you took before. Law and order. I know.
我更喜欢哪一个，是发现某人演过《神探阿蒙》还是《豪斯医生》。你就是喜欢看到《豪斯医生》里出现客座明星。我知道。当他们演过《豪斯医生》。成了我的最爱。我也喜欢追踪人们是否在《法律与秩序》里扮演过不止一个角色。我喜欢你刚才在“法律与秩序”前面做出的那个长长的停顿。我知道。
That's the summer cold. That is summer cold as you just one second delayed. It's like you're on a satellite feed. Well Pam's going to have a talking head now where she says there's a few ways you can get promoted. One, you can wait for an opening, a new job, you apply for it. That's the main way. Or this way, where you just apparently lie yourself into a new job.
那是夏季感冒。那是夏季感冒带来的延迟，让你慢了一秒钟。就像你在听卫星信号直播一样。嗯，帕姆现在要进行一段单人采访，她说有几种方法可以升职。第一种，你可以等待一个空缺的新职位，然后去申请。这是主要的方法。或者像这样，你显然靠说谎把自己“骗”进了一个新职位。
So Pam is going to go into the kitchen, she's going to make herself a cup of tea. Oscar's like, what's up with your new position? Congratulations. And she's clearly trying to suss out from Oscar, what is a reasonable salary for this position. She's like, yeah, I'm going to make 40k, maybe 50. He's like, 50. She's like, no, it's like 41.5. Yeah, 41.5. Lady, we got some mail about this storyline,
所以帕姆走进厨房，给自己泡了一杯茶。奥斯卡说，你的新职位是怎么回事？恭喜啊。她显然是在试探奥斯卡，这个职位合理的薪水是多少。她就像，对，我要挣4万美元，也许5万。他就像，5万。她就像，不，大约是4.15万。对，4.15万。女士们，我们收到了关于这条故事线的来信，
and both of these delighted me. I feel so proud. The first one is from Kelly M. in Melbourne, Australia, who said, a couple of years ago, I was inspired by Pam's storyline in this episode where she just starts telling people she's the office administrator. So I did it myself. What? Yeah. She said, I work in a school. And a couple of years ago, I decided we really needed a sustainability coordinator.
这两封信都让我欣喜若狂。我感到好自豪。第一封来自澳大利亚墨尔本的凯莉·M，她说，几年前，我受到这一集中帕姆的故事线的启发，她开始到处告诉别人她是办公室行政人员。所以我自己也这么做了。什么？对。她说，我在一所学校工作。几年前，我决定我们真的需要一个可持续发展协调员。
Okay. But it's quite hard to get new roles off the ground because of budgets and things. So I decided to just start calling myself the sustainability coordinator. I added sustainability coordinator to my email signature, and I even sent some letters to businesses asking for donations of plants from the local nursery etc. and signed off as the sustainability coordinator. Oh my gosh. I am loving Kelly, I just have to say.
好吧。但由于预算等原因，要开展新职位相当困难。所以我决定直接开始自称为可持续发展协调员。我在电子邮件签名里加上了可持续发展协调员，我甚至给一些企业写信，请求当地苗圃等赞助捐赠植物，落款签名就是可持续发展协调员。天哪。我太喜欢凯莉了，我必须得说。
Kelly went on to say, the next year I added it as a suggestion to a list of new roles that were being created and the school agreed. Kelly, this is the slow play. I know, this was like a year. Like a year in the making. I am intrigued. Continue. They created an official position and gave it to me.
凯莉接着说，第二年，我把它作为建议写进了一份正在创建的新职位列表中，学校同意了。凯莉，你这招真是谋划长远啊。我知道，这就像是一整年。历时整整一年呢。我很感兴趣。请继续。他们创建了一个官方职位并交给了我。
It's been a couple of years now and we now have a team of five teachers and a student club. Kelly! We do heaps of fun things like plant trees, collect batteries and other recycling and all sorts of things. Thanks for the inspiration, Pam. Wow! Amazing, right?
几年过去了，我们现在拥有了一个由五名教师和一个学生俱乐部组成的团队。凯莉！我们做了很多有趣的事情，比如种树、收集电池和其他回收物以及各种各样的事。感谢你的启发，帕姆。哇！太棒了，对吧？
Amazing. I did just catch myself, guys. I think I got a saying wrong. What is it? I said Kelly did the slow play. Is it the long play? The slow play? You've combined long play and slow burn.
太棒了。我刚才抓包了自己，伙计们。我觉得我有个词说错了。是什么？我说凯莉用了“慢盘布局（slow play）”。难道是“长线布局（long play）”？慢盘布局？你把“长线布局（long play）”和“温水煮青蛙（slow burn）”结合起来了。
Slow game? Slow burn. Slow burn. Long play. Long play. Slow burn. You created your own slow play. Slow play.
慢棋？温水煮青蛙。长线布局。温水煮青蛙。你自己创造了一个“慢盘布局”。慢盘布局。
That's very you, Angela. Well, Kelly, I'm impressed with your slow play. Guess what? I liked it so much, it sounded so right to me, that I went with it. The slow play. Guess what? I liked it so much. It sounded so right to me that I went with it. The slow play. Thank you. We got another one from Megan H. in Albany, New York. Megan said, this episode inspired me to make up a new job title for myself.
这很符合你的风格，安吉拉。好吧，凯莉，我对你的长线布局印象深刻。你猜怎么着？我太喜欢它了，听起来那么贴切，所以我就顺着它用了。长线布局。你猜怎么着？我太喜欢它了。听起来那么贴切，所以我就顺着它用了。长线布局。谢谢。我们收到了来自纽约州奥尔巴尼的梅根·H的另一封信。梅根说，这一集启发了我为自己编造了一个新职位。
What, Megan? I was rewatching the episode and when Pam says this could work too, I thought, huh, that could work. So I wrote up a very fancy report with a made-up job title, went to my boss and said, before you came in, the old boss and I were discussing this change. He approved the idea, I got a new title and a $10,000 raise. Oh my gosh! I know! Pretty amazing. Pam, inspiring people to just go for it. Yeah.
什么，梅根？我在重温这一集，当帕姆说这或许也行得通时，我想，哈，那也许真的行得通。所以我写了一份非常花哨的报告，上面写着一个凭空捏造的职位头衔，走到老板面前说，在你来之前，前任老板和我一直在讨论这个变动。他批准了这个想法，我得到了一个新头衔和1万美元的加薪。哦，天哪！我知道！太厉害了。帕姆，激励着人们勇敢去争取。是的。
Creating jobs for themselves and getting them approved. I want a new title for my emails. What is Angela's new job title? Anyone? I'm going to go with Ham Coordinator. Ham Coordinator. I was going to go with Boss Bitch. Oh my gosh.
为自己创造职位并获得批准。我也想给我的邮件换个新头衔。安吉拉的新职位头衔是什么？有人知道吗？我选“火腿协调员”。火腿协调员。我本来想选“霸气女老板（boss bitch）”。哦，天哪。
Those are not similar. Angela Kinsey, boss bitch. I'd like them both at the end of an email. Angela Kinsey, boss bitch hyphen ham coordinator. Hmm. I look forward to that email. Okay. On our next business email. I'll just sign off Angela Kinsey, boss bitch.
这两个一点也不像。安吉拉·金西，霸气女老板。我希望这两个都出现在邮件末尾。安吉拉·金西，霸气女老板 - 兼火腿协调员。嗯。我很期待那封邮件。好的。在我们的下一封商务邮件里。我直接落款安吉拉·金西，霸气女老板。
I know. Our company is Ramble. That's the name of our media company, everybody. Next time someone calls, I'm going to say, you know what? I'm going to go ahead and forward you to our boss bitch, Angela Kinsey. She can address that issue for you. Well, let's go back to therapy in the break room. Michael is just continuing to make up a bunch of baloney
我知道。我们公司叫朗布尔（Ramble）。那是我们媒体公司的名字，各位。下次有人打电话来，我就说，你知道吗？我这就把你转接给我们的霸气女老板安吉拉·金西。她可以为你解决那个问题。好吧，让我们回到休息室里的心理治疗。迈克尔一直在继续对托比胡说八道。
to Toby. I have to think this went to our standards and practices department when he said, well, the other night, I was sitting at the table eating my penis. I mean, peas. And he's pretty sure he was probed by an alien life force, Alf. It might have actually been Alf. Yeah, then he's pretty sure he was probed by an alien life force, Alf. It might have actually been Alf.
我想当他说出这些时，这肯定通过了我们的标准与实践部门审核，他说，嗯，前天晚上，我坐在桌旁吃我的“阴茎”。我是说，豌豆。而且他很确信自己被外星生命形式——阿尔夫（Alf）探测过了。其实那可能真的是阿尔夫。对，然后他很确信自己被外星生命形式——阿尔夫探测过了。其实那可能真的是阿尔夫。
Yeah, then he's going to tell Toby that he was raised by wolves. Wolves? I believe he says wolves. And it's interesting, Angela, because it made me go to the script. And first of all, this whole wolf bit, you know, he ends up howling and everything. That was actually from our must-shoot candy bag. So that was an ad. And there was extra that went with it, where Toby said, don't you mean wolves? And he said, no, Toby, it's not called Little Red Riding Hood and the
对，然后他要告诉托比他是被狼抚养长大的。狼？我相信他说的是狼。有趣的是，安吉拉，因为这让我去翻了剧本。首先，整个狼的这个桥段，你知道的，他最后又是狼嚎什么的。这其实来自我们必须拍摄的糖果包镜头。所以那是个即兴发挥。还有额外的内容，托比说，你难道不是指狼吗？他说，不，托比，这不叫《小红帽与》
Big Bad Wolf. That was the joke, that he was going to say it's wolves, because it's a wolf. That was the joke that he was going to say it's wolves because it's a wolf. Well, that would explain that line. I also was tickled when he said I was 25 years old before I saw my first human being. That's how long he lived in the forest. Toby is finally going to agree with Michael that this is pointless, you know? That's right. And he's going to say, why don't we just run out the clock of your counseling sessions by playing games? And he brought some fun stuff that he plays with his daughter. Michael seems happy with this. Yes. Meanwhile, Jim has brought Dwight up to front reception and the entire group is going to help transform him into a rich snob.
大坏狼。那是他们的笑话，他会说是狼，因为那是一只狼。那是他们的笑话，他会说是狼因为那是一只狼。好吧，那就能解释那句台词了。当他说“我25岁才见到第一个人类”时，我也觉得很好笑。他就是在那森林里生活了那么久。托比最终会同意迈克尔的看法，认为这毫无意义，对吧？没错。他会说，我们为什么不通过玩游戏来打发你的心理咨询时间呢？他还带了一些他跟女儿一起玩的好玩的东东。迈克尔对此似乎很高兴。是的。与此同时，吉姆把德怀特带到了前台接待处，整个团队都要帮他改造成一个富有势利的家伙。
One by one, they're going to like pick apart his wardrobe, his glasses, do we like them, do we not? We stopped on them. Too late, too late. We've crushed them. Too bad. Kelly says his shirt is Disgusto Barfo. This scene was actually bigger and it showed who contributed to his final outfit.
他们要一个接一个地挑剔他的衣橱、他的眼镜，我们喜欢吗，还是不喜欢？我们在上面停了下来。太迟了，太迟了。我们已经把它们压碎了。太糟了。凯利说他的衬衫是“恶心巴巴”。这个场景其实更宏大，它展示了谁为他最终的行头做出了贡献。
Oh. Yes, in the shooting draft, Andy gives Dwight his vest, Jim gives Dwight his suit jacket, Creed gives him an old pipe that he stole from a museum, Kevin gives him a slightly used handkerchief, and they use Phyllis' scarf as an ascot. Wow! So I spotted that that was Andy's vest, but I didn't know where the other elements came from.
哦。是的，在拍摄剧本中，安迪把他的背心给了德怀特，吉姆把他的西装外套给了德怀特，克里德给了他一根从博物馆偷来的旧烟斗，凯文给了他一条用过几次的手帕，他们还把菲莉丝的围巾当成了阿斯科特领巾。哇！所以我看出那是安迪的背心，但我不知道其他元素是从哪里来的。
Thank you, Angela. In addition to dressing him differently, they're also going to give him some tips on, I don't know how to communicate with people. Daryl suggests he say, good morning, good afternoon, because people like that, to which Dwight responds, I see you every day. Can I say good month? That is a rain Dwight crossover. Oh, that was 100% rain. Totally rain. Rain with love, nothing more than to say good month. Yeah. And just get it all done. Yeah. He loves you. He's glad you had a good month. We don't need
谢谢你，安吉拉。除了给他换身行头，他们还要给他一些关于——我不知道该怎么跟人交流的建议。达里尔建议他说，早上好，下午好，因为人们喜欢这样，对此德怀特回答说，我每天都见到你。我能说“月安”吗？那是德怀特的专属跨界梗。哦，那百分之百是德怀特。完全是德怀特。德怀特带着爱，除了说声月安什么也没有。是啊。然后把它全部说完。是啊。他爱你。他很高兴你过了一个美好的月份。我们不需要
to rehash everything every day. That's right. So they're done. They're ready to go. Everyone agrees. He looks great. Yeah, go get him, Dwight. Erin's going to take a picture with her disposable camera. And then throw it right in the trash. Yeah. She has a talking head where she says disposable cameras are fun, but it seems wasteful because you never get to see your pictures. Oh, Erin.
每天把所有事情都重申一遍。没错。所以他们完成了。他们准备好了。大家一致同意。他看起来棒极了。去吧，去找他，德怀特。艾琳要用她的得力一次性相机拍张照。然后直接把它扔进垃圾桶。是的。她有一个单采镜头，里面说一次性相机很有趣，但似乎很浪费，因为你永远看不到你的照片。噢，艾琳。
We had a fan question from Taylor in Athens, Georgia, who absolutely loves this talking head, this moment with the disposable camera, who wanted to say hats off to the writers, the director, and Ellie. Lady, when this episode originally aired, this talking head, it blew up the message boards. Yeah. This was like, it reminds me of something you'd see in the movie Airplane. You know what I mean? Yeah.
我们收到了一个来自佐治亚州雅典市的泰勒的粉丝提问，他超级喜欢这个单采镜头，这个使用一次性相机的时刻，他想向编剧、导演和艾莉致敬。天哪，当这集最初播出时，这个单采镜头直接在留言板上炸锅了。是啊。这就好像，让我想起你在电影《空前绝后满天飞》里看到的场景。你知道我的意思吗？是啊。
Shirley, you can't be serious. I am serious and don't call me Shirley. Like it's one of- What's your Victor vector? Exactly. It's right in that like comedy lane. And we threw it in there. I think only the character of Aaron could get away with this joke.
雪莉，你不是认真的吧。我是认真的，别叫我雪莉。就像它是其中一个——你的维克托·韦克托是什么？没、错。它完全就在那种喜剧赛道上。我们把它加进去了。我觉得只有艾琳这个角色才能逃过这个笑话的吐槽。
Oh, for sure. Aaron or Creed? Yeah, maybe Creed. You're right. Sidebar note, all the black and white photos in our book, The Office BFFs, were taken with my black and white disposable camera. Oh, yeah.
哦，肯定的。艾琳还是克里德？对，也许是克里德。你说的对。插播一条，我们书《办公室好闺蜜》里的所有黑白照片都是用我的黑白一次性相机拍的。哦，是的。
I bought a disposable camera, but just black and white film. I thought it'd be so cool. And I took all these pictures. And then I took it to the kiosk in the mall and got my photos photos and they're in the book. I'm pretty sure all my photos from the pilot that we put in the book were also a disposable camera. That was like how we did it. I know. It's crazy to think about. When we did our book, I found all these pictures as did Jenna and I found like the little disc they would give you. Yeah, they'd put it on a CD-ROM. Yeah, and I found those.
我买了一台一次性相机，但是只有黑白胶卷。我觉得这会超级酷。我拍了所有这些照片。然后我把它带到商场的照相亭冲洗了照片，它们就在书里了。我挺确凿地认为我们在书里放的那个试播集的所有照片也都是一次性相机拍的。当时我们就是这么干的。我知道。想起来真疯狂。当我们写书的时候，我和詹娜一样找到了所有这些照片，我还找到了他们会给你的那种小盘片。对，他们会把它刻在CD-ROM上。对，我找到了那些。
I had to go buy a thing so I could play it. To connect it to my computer so I could look at the pictures. Jenna bought the thing and then we kept sharing it back and forth. She'd drop it off to me, I'd bring it to her, and then eventually my husband was like, should I just buy you? It's $12.99, ladies. I think you can each have one. I finally got one. Well, for those of you keeping track of the Duangela romance, Angela
我得去买个东西，好让我能播放它。把它连接到我的电脑上，这样我才能看照片。詹娜买了那个东西，然后我们俩就一直借来借去。她把它放到我这儿，我把它带给她，然后最后我丈夫就说，我是不是应该直接给你买一个？女士们，只要12.99美元。我想你们俩可以一人买一个。我终于买了一个。好吧，对于你们这些一直在关注“德安吉拉”恋情的人来说，安吉拉
snags Dwight right before he leaves and says, hey, my place tonight, wear this. Don't forget your pipe. Yeah, she's liking this whole new look. And then she gets out her procreation punch card. Yeah, Dwight's like, do you have your card? Yeah. So baby making on the way here. What punch is this? Is this punch two? She used one punch for down in the warehouse. I think this is punch two. Yeah. And then, well, next week in Andy's play, you'll see what happens. Oh boy. Punch three?
在德怀特离开前一把抓住他并说道：嘿，今晚我那儿，穿这身。别忘了你的烟斗。是的，她很喜欢这个全新的造型。然后她拿出了她的造人生育打孔卡。对，德怀特就像是，你带卡了吗？对，所以去这里的路上就要造小孩了。这是第几次打孔？这是第二次打孔吗？她在仓库里用了一次打孔。我想这是第二次打孔。是的。然后，好吧，下周在安迪的戏剧里，你就会看到会发生什么。哦，天哪。第三次打孔？
No. Oh. Save it for next week, lady. You've already watched it. I haven't watched it because of my summer cold. I'm behind. It's a fun one. Well, back in the break room, Toby and Michael are playing Connect 4. What did it cost us to use Connect 4? Do we have deets? Oh, well, Randy didn't tell me the cost, but he said they gave us permission to use the game provided we didn't throw the game at Toby or show it being knocked off the table. Okay. But then it was fine. All right.
不。哦。留到下周再说吧，女士。你已经看过了。我因为夏日感冒还没看呢。我进度落后了。这是一个有趣的故事。好吧，回到休息室，托比和迈克尔在玩“四子棋”。我们用“四子棋”花了多少钱？我们有细节吗？哦，好吧，兰迪没有告诉我费用，但他说他们允许我们使用这个游戏，前提是我们不能把游戏扔向托比或者把它从桌子上撞下去。好的。但后来一切都好。好吧。
So, yes. Well, Connect 4 is working. Michael is sharing. Toby is like, oh my gosh, it's happening. Yeah, he's sharing all about Jeff, this breakthrough moment where Michael says that his stepdad Jeff respected the manager. Yeah. Michael's a manager. Michael's a manager. Still trying to get Jeff's favor. Aw. We got mail lady from Vicki S. in Gulfport, Mississippi who said, I have been a children's therapist since 1995, and I think Toby did
所以，是的。好吧，“四子棋”起作用了。迈克尔在分享。托比就像，哦天哪，它正在发生。是的，他分享了所有关于杰夫的事，这是一个突破性的时刻，迈克尔说他的继父杰夫尊重经理。是的。迈克尔是经理。迈克尔是经理。还在努力争取杰夫的青睐。啊。我们收到了来自密西西比州格尔夫波特的维琪·S.的粉丝来信，她说，我自1995年起就是一名儿童治疗师，我认为托比
an excellent job utilizing games as a tool to get Michael to talk. Great job writers. And Laura L. from Kansas City, Missouri said, I'm a social worker and sometimes therapist, and this episode has been used in trainings. This episode? Yes, to demonstrate the therapeutic power of play. Toby knows his skills. I would have never imagined that this episode
在利用游戏作为工具让迈克尔开口说话这方面做得非常出色。编剧们干得漂亮。来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的劳拉·L.说，我是一名社会工作者，有时也是治疗师，这一集曾被用在培训中。这一集？是的，用来展示游戏的治疗力量。托比很懂他的专业技能。我从来没有想过这一集
is a training video. They move on from Connect 4 to playing cards. And Michael's going to share a story about his dog running away and how he wouldn't go back to the park where the dog ran away because he was afraid he would see his dog there with someone else. Yes. Playing with another kid. And Toby says, it's very important for you to be liked, isn't it?
竟然是一个培训视频。他们从“四子棋”转到了玩纸牌。迈克尔要分享一个关于他的狗跑掉的故事，以及为什么他不会回到狗跑掉的公园，因为他害怕在那里看到他的狗和别人在一起。是的。和另一个小孩一起玩。托比说，被人喜欢对你来说非常重要，不是吗？
And Michael's like, oh no. He escalates so quickly. Like he just goes off. He's so mad that Toby got him to be vulnerable. Yeah, he gives him the finger and he walks out. Yeah. Guess what? Standards and practices. Stepping in.
迈克尔就像是，哦不。他情绪升级得太快了。就像他直接爆发了。他太生气了，因为托比竟然让他变得脆弱。是的，他向托比竖了中指然后走了出去。是的。你猜怎么着？标准与实践部门。介入了。
We had to blur the double bird. Here were their exact words. It's my new favorite thing. Is this from Randy? Yep. Quote, please blur Michael's hands as he flips the bird, in parentheses, you, to Toby during the counseling session. I like how they had to spell it out, in case we thought it was another bird. Maybe there's a random bird.
我们必须给双中指打码。以下是他们的原话。这是我的新最爱。这是兰迪说的吗？没错。原话是，请在咨询期间给迈克尔向托比竖起中指（括号内注明：你）的手打上马赛克。我喜欢他们必须把话说得明明白白的样子，以防我们以为那是别的什么鸟。也许有一只随机的鸟。
No. No, it's the F-U bird. And lady, I have one more piece of mail from Stephanie Ellen St. Louis talking about Toby's therapy. Stephanie said, I'm a therapist. And while the inconsistencies with professional ethics don't bug me, I do need to point them out in this episode.
不。不，就是那个F-U的鸟。而且，女士，我还有一封来自圣路易斯的斯蒂芬妮·艾伦的来信，谈到了托比的治疗。斯蒂芬妮说，我是一名治疗师。虽然专业道德方面的不一致并没有困扰我，但我确实需要在这集里指出它们。
Number one, Toby would need to be licensed in Pennsylvania, which would typically require him to actively be practicing over the years. It's not enough just to have a diploma. Okay. Okay. Number two, there is a major conflict of interest in having Toby be Michael's counselor because you're not allowed to have a dual relationship with a client. So ethically, he should have referred Michael to someone else.
第一，托比需要在宾夕法尼亚州获得执照，这通常需要他在这些年里积极执业。光有一张文凭是不够的。好吧。好吧。第二，让托比担任迈克尔的顾问存在重大的利益冲突，因为你不能与客户建立双重关系。所以在道德上，他应该把迈克尔推荐给其他人。
Although, Stephanie points out, that would not be nearly as funny. True, Stephanie. True. Yes. Number three, I work with kids and teens doing trauma therapy at a children's advocacy center and the game strategy that Toby uses is something I do all the time when there's a kid who doesn't want to be at counseling. Uno is literally a lifesaver. Aww. So that's the part that we got right.
尽管，斯蒂芬妮指出，那可就没那么有趣了。确实如此，斯蒂芬妮。确实如此。是的。第三，我在儿童倡导中心与儿童和青少年一起做创伤治疗，托比使用的游戏策略是我每当遇到一个不想去咨询的小孩时都会做的事情。UNO纸牌简直是救星。啊。所以这是我们做对的部分。
Well Pam is going to start putting her plan in motion. She goes up to Gabe. This made me sweat. This scene made me sweat. I was like, oh my God Pam, oh my God. She goes, you know what? I haven't been paid yet. I'm not blaming you. I'm not blaming you.
好吧，帕姆要开始付诸她的计划了。她走向盖布。这让我直冒汗。这个场景让我直冒汗。我当时想，哦天哪，帕姆，哦天哪。她说，你知道吗？我还没拿到工资呢。我不是在怪你。我不是在怪你。
I'm not blaming anyone. I'm sure it just got lost in the paperwork. Gabe is so relieved that Pam isn't upset with him. And he's like, you know what? Will you get the department head signatures so we can really get the ball rolling here? Yes. And Pam explains that this office has a lot of one-person departments. So there are a lot of department heads.
我没有怪任何人。我确信它只是在文书工作里弄丢了。盖布听到帕姆没有生他的气，顿时松了一口气。他说，你知道吗？你能去拿一下部门主管的签字吗，这样我们才能真正让事情进展起来？是的。帕姆解释说，这个办公室有很多一人部门。所以有很多部门主管。
Which I didn't realize. I didn't realize Meredith was the head of a department. Yeah. Isn't she the head of quality control or something? Isn't it just her and Creed? I don't know. I wasn't sure. But first she goes in and gets Michael's signature. He is still upset about his counseling. He doesn't look at the form.
我之前都没意识到。我没意识到梅雷迪思是一个部门的主管。是的。她不是质量控制部门的主管什么的吗？难道不是只有她和克里德吗？我不知道。我不太确定。但首先她进去拿了迈克尔的签字。他还在为他的咨询事宜生闷气。他连表格都没看一眼。
He doesn't ask her any questions. Then she's going to go over to Meredith. What are you doing in this scene? It looks like you're, I don't know what you're doing, a dance move, you're kind of, what is this? Yes, we got questions about this. Abby S. from Atlanta, Georgia would also like to know what the hell is Pam saying or doing with Meredith?
他没有问她任何问题。然后她要去找梅雷迪思。你在这一幕里干嘛呢？你看起来像是在，我不知道你在干嘛，一个跳舞的动作，你有点像，这到底是什么？是的，我们收到了关于这个的问题。来自佐治亚州亚特兰大的阿比·S.也想知道帕姆到底在对梅雷迪思说些什么或做些什么。
Larissa W. from Littleton, Colorado says, did I have scripted lines or was I improvising? Because it's, you know, voiceover with a talking head. Here's what it said in the script. B-Roll. Pam makes ribbled humping gesture by Meredith's desk. I thought it was a humping gesture, but I didn't want to throw that out there in case this was some dance move. I didn't know.
来自科罗拉多州利特尔顿的拉里萨·W.说，我有台词剧本还是在即兴发挥？因为那是，你知道的，配音加单采镜头。剧本上是这么写的。B卷。帕姆在梅雷迪思的桌子旁做了个下流的猥亵动作。我以为是个猥亵动作，但我不想直接说出来，万一这是某种舞蹈动作呢。我不知道。
Well, first of all, when I read the stage direction, I had to look up the definition of ribald. And it means referring to a sexual matter in an amusingly coarse or irreverent way. A synonym is body. And I'll have you know, standards and practices, when they read the script, they had something to say about this gesture. Please tell me what they said. They said, quote, please use your discretion staging the scene where Pam makes a quote, ribbled humping gesture. It should play as funny, not explicit. Man, Pam is working it. She knows what's going to work with each person. She really does. It says at Angela's desk,
好吧，首先，当我读到舞台说明时，我不得不去查一下“下流”这个词的定义。它的意思是：以一种有趣而粗俗或不敬的方式提及性方面的事务。一个同义词是“猥亵”。我得告诉你们，标准与实践部门在读剧本时，对这个动作可是有话说。请告诉我他们说了什么。他们说，原话是：请在编排帕姆做一个引用自“下流的猥亵动作”的场景时自行斟酌。它应该表现得搞笑，而不是露骨。天哪，帕姆太会了。她知道什么对每个人都管用。她真的很会。剧本上说在安吉拉的桌子旁，
Pam points to various cat pictures and rearranges them more nicely on her desk, lighting Angela up who signs as she talks. Then Pam is gonna go into Daryl's office and he's very interested in her new position because he might like to have corkboard all over his office because it's something that he saw that Kate Walsh has done to her home office. He saw it on TV.
帕姆指着各种猫咪照片，把它们在桌子上重新排列得更整洁一些，这让安吉拉容光焕发，边说话边签了字。然后帕姆要走进达里尔的办公室，他对她的新职位非常感兴趣，因为他可能也想在办公室里铺满软木板，因为这是他看到凯特·沃尔什对她的家庭办公室做过的事。他在电视上看到的。
This got me so tickled. You guys know Kate Walsh is one of my good, good pals. We go way back to our improv days. Jenna, you know, you even did improv with us one time. Oh, yeah, that's right. Yeah. Oh my God. We drug you into one of our improv shows. But you guys might also know her as Addison from Grey's Anatomy, plus a gazillion other things she's done. So when I saw Daryl mention
这把我逗乐坏了。你们知道凯特·沃尔什是我的好闺蜜之一。我们从即兴表演的年代就认识了。詹娜，你知道的，你甚至还跟我们一起做过一次即兴表演。哦，对，没错。是啊。哦天哪。我们把你拉进了我们的一个即兴表演节目里。但你们也可能知道她是《实习医生格蕾》里的艾迪生，外加她演过的其他无数个角色。所以当我看到达里尔提到
her, I was like, oh my God. So I called Kate and I said, Kate, did you know you're mentioned in this office episode by Daryl? And she was like, No, I had no idea. And I said, Yeah, I mean, Daryl in the episode says he saw your home office and it's covered in corkboard. What do you have to say about that? And here's what she had to say. Hi, this is Kate Walsh. I have never had a home office covered in corkboard, but now I'm wondering why I haven't. That sounds delightful. I do love a pin board. I love her so much.
她时，我当时想，哦天哪。所以我给凯特打了电话，我说，凯特，你知道你在这一集的《办公室》里被达里尔提到了吗？她说，不，我完全不知道。我说，是啊，我是说，达里尔在这一集里说他看到了你的家庭办公室，上面贴满了软木板。你对此有什么想说的吗？以下是她的回应：嗨，我是凯特·沃尔什。我从来没有把家庭办公室贴满软木板，但现在我在想我为什么没有这么做。听起来真不错。我确实很喜欢钉板。我太爱她了。
Thanks, Kate. I love it. much. Thanks Kate. I love it. Well, I spotted something in Daryl's office. It's not corkboard, but it's 16 minutes and 53 seconds. There's a blue football helmet with a white paw print hanging on his coat rack thing. Yeah, I saw it too. It's the Valley View High School Cougars football helmet.
谢谢你，凯特。我太喜欢了。很多。谢谢凯特。我太喜欢了。好吧，我在达里尔的办公室里发现了一点。那不是软木板，但在16分53秒时。他的衣帽架上挂着一个带白色爪印的蓝色美式橄榄球头盔。是的，我也看到了。那是山景高中美洲狮队的橄榄球头盔。
And I just thought that was an amazing detail. And that's where Pam went to high school. And I guess Daryl did too and played football? With Roy, probably. Maybe so. Well, full Pam might be in trouble. Oh, no. Because Gabe said he's gone through three years worth of information and can't find
我只是觉得这是一个了不起的细节。那是帕姆读高中的地方。我猜达里尔也是，还打过橄榄球？大概跟罗伊一起吧。也许吧。好吧，帕姆的好日子可能要遇到麻烦了。哦，不。因为盖布说他查阅了三年的资料，却找不到
anything about Pam being the office administrator. He says he doesn't want to accuse her of anything, so maybe she could just admit. Pam's like, admit what? Pam realizes that Gabe is so afraid of confrontation that he will not accuse her of being a liar or making it up. He won't do it. He won't do it. And then he folds and Pam says, let me know if you need a new chair or anything that an
任何关于帕姆是办公室管理员的记录。他说他不想指责她什么，所以也许她可以自己承认。帕姆就像是，承认什么？帕姆意识到盖布太害怕对峙了，以至于他不会指责她是个骗子或是凭空捏造。他不会这么做的。他不会这么做的。然后他妥协了，帕姆说，如果你需要一把新椅子或者任何办公室管理员能处理的事情，随时告诉我。
office administrator can handle. And then he folds and Pam says, let me know if you need a new chair or anything that an office administrator can handle. And Gabe says, can I get one of those nameplates that says Gabe Lewis? Pam says, sure. Anything else? He says, nope. And that's it. She's office administrator. It's done. Pam has a talking head where she says the first lesson of watching World Poker Tour at 2 a.m. You play the opponent, not the cards. Lady, we got a fan question from Natalie F. in San Antonio, Texas, who would like to know, what do you guys think about the way Pam gets her promotion? The first time I watched it,
然后他妥协了，帕姆说，如果你需要一把新椅子或者任何办公室管理员能处理的事情，随时告诉我。而盖布说，我能要那种写着“盖布·刘易斯”的姓名牌吗？帕姆说，当然。还有别的吗？他说，没了。就这样。她是办公室管理员了。搞定。帕姆有一个单采镜头，里面说凌晨两点看世界扑克巡回赛的第一课。你玩的是对手，而不是手里的牌。女士，我们收到了来自得克萨斯州圣安东尼奥市娜塔莉·F.的粉丝提问，她想知道，你们怎么看帕姆获得晋升的方式？我第一次看的时候，
I was excited for her, but in rewatching it, I was kind of bothered by her dishonesty. What do we think? I mean, Natalie, it's a little layered, right? Because I'm so happy Pam finally was an advocate for herself and made something happen. Natalie, I lied all the time when I was an up and coming actress. If I had an audition, I lied and said I had a dental appointment. It was just easier. To get out of work. Yeah.
我为她感到兴奋，但在重看时，我有点被她的不诚实困扰了。我们怎么看？我是说，娜塔莉，这有点多层含义，对吧？因为我太高兴帕姆终于为自己挺身而出并促成了一些事情。娜塔莉，当我还是个崭露头角的演员时，我经常撒谎。如果我有试镜，我会撒谎说我有牙科预约。这样比较容易。为了逃避工作。是啊。
Well, you guys know how I got my internship on Conan O'Brien. That's what I was going to say. You shared that. You totally just lied your way into it. I just kept calling and saying, yeah, I just booked someone. They said I'm hired. I know. I guess it begs the question, like, when is it unethical and when is it ambition? When is it to be admired and when is it to be faulted? Yeah, I think it's layered Natalie. I'm happy for her in this moment. I bet Mike Schur's book, How to Be Perfect, would tell us the moral answer to this question.
好吧，你们知道我是怎么在柯南·奥布莱恩那里得到实习机会的。我正要说呢。你分享过这个。你完全就是靠撒谎混进去的。我只是不停地打电话说，对，我刚帮某个人敲定通告了。他们说我被录用了。我知道。我想这就引出了一个问题，那就是，什么时候是不道德的，什么时候是野心？什么时候该被钦佩，什么时候该被指责？是的，我觉得这很有层次感，娜塔莉。我为她在这个时刻感到高兴。我打赌迈克尔·舒尔的书《如何做到完美》会告诉我们这个问题的道德答案。
Yes. Perhaps we should ask him. Did Pam getting this position benefit everyone else in the office? Were their lives made better? So is lying okay if you make other people's lives better? See, that's complicated. It's very complicated. And also, you know, people were really liking this moment at first of Pam, but as we get
是的。也许我们应该去问问他。帕姆得到这个职位对办公室里的其他人有好处吗？他们的生活变得更好了吗？所以，如果你让别人的生活变得更好，撒谎是可以的吗？你看，这很复杂。这非常复杂。而且，你知道，人们一开始真的很喜欢帕姆的这个时刻，但随着我们深入
into some of the things she's going to do as office administrator, people turned on her. Yeah. We'll discuss it. And when I say people, I mean fans turned on the storyline because Pam starts kind of using her power in ways that maybe are not appropriate. People didn't care for it.
了解她作为办公室管理员将要做的一些事情，人们开始反感她了。是的。我们会讨论这个。当我说是人们时，我是指粉丝们开始反感这个剧情线，因为帕姆开始以某种可能不太恰当的方式行使她的权力。人们不太喜欢这样。
Natalie, great question. Lady, let's go to the mall. Mm-hmm. Because Jim and Andy have brought Dwight to Precious Heirlooms to confront the salesperson. To get his revenge. But the salesperson recognizes Dwight. He's like, oh, I remember you.
娜塔莉，问得好。女士，我们去商场吧。嗯哼。因为吉姆和安迪把德怀特带到了“珍贵传家宝”店去质问销售员。去报复他。但销售员认出了德怀特。他说，哦，我记得你。
Yes, you were here yesterday. We took a picture. We were worried. You had blood stains on your hands, and you were wearing overalls. And Jim is like, what? Huh? And yes, there we see why they denied Dwight entry. He has his hands. They're all red. They're on the
是的，你昨天来过。我们拍了张照。我们当时很担心。你手上沾满了血迹，还穿着工作服。而吉姆就像是，什么？啊？是的，我们从这里看到了他们拒绝德怀特入内的原因。他的手上。全都是红色的。它们在
glass of precious heirlooms. But Dwight is still going to try to have his pretty woman moment. He is. He still wants to go pretty woman on their ass. And I have the question for you. I'm titling this, Who Did It Best? Julia? Hi! Hello! Do you remember me? No, I'm sorry.
“珍贵传家宝”的玻璃上。但德怀特还是要试图上演他的《漂亮女人》时刻。他会的。他仍然想对他们这群人上演《漂亮女人》那一套。我有个问题要问你们。我把这题命名为“谁演得最好？”茱莉亚？嗨！你好！你还记得我吗？不，不好意思。
I was in here yesterday. You wouldn't wait on me? Oh. You work on commission, right? Uh, yes. Big mistake. Big. Huge.
我昨天来过这里。你当时不肯接待我？哦。你是拿提成的，对吧？呃，对。大错特错。大错特错。
I have to go shopping now. Or Dwight. When I came to your finest now. Or Dwight. When I came to your finest... You are... I'm gonna... Okay. Listen. You can't treat me. Thank you. Good morning, sir. Okay. Let's go. You made a big mistake. Huge. There it is.
我现在必须去购物了。或者德怀特。当我来到你最好的……你……我要……好吧。听着。你不能这样对……谢谢。早上好，先生。好的。我们走。你犯了个大错。大错特错。就是这样。
I mean, Dwight just keeps... He's like this robot that's malfunctioning. He's like, good morning, good day, sir. Hello, top of the morning. What? How dare you? Yes. Well, lady, I've got another guest star alert. Eric Zuckerman played the salesperson, and I've got an interesting bit of trivia on Eric
我是说，德怀特一直在……他就像个发生故障的机器人。他就像是，早上好，先生。你好，早安。什么？你怎么敢？是的。好吧，女士，我还有一个客串明星警报。埃里克·祖克曼饰演了那个销售员，我关于埃里克有一个有趣的冷知识，
because he falls into my other favorite category that I mentioned. He has not only played two different characters in two different episodes of Law and Order, he's also done it on Law and Order Criminal Intent. Multiple characters across the franchise! Yes. He's also had recurring roles on Revenge and Orange is the New Black. I also have a bag breakdown. Dwight's bags? Yeah, all of his shopping bags? One of them is a Steamtown mall bag and the other is from a store called La Tida.
因为他落入了提到的我的另一个最爱类别。他不仅在《法律与秩序》的两集里扮演了两个不同的角色，他还在《法律与秩序：洛杉矶/犯罪倾向》里做过同样的事。横跨整个系列的多个角色！是的。他还在《复仇》和《女子监狱》中饰演过常驻角色。我还有一个购物袋盘点。德怀特的袋子？对，他所有的购物袋？其中一个是蒸汽镇商场的袋子，另一个来自一家叫“La Tida”的商店。
Have we featured La Tida before? I'm not sure, but they're a real store in the Steamtown mall. They were there from the day it opened until it closed in 2019. What did La Tida sell? They sold like fancy trinkets and nice items for your house for giving gifts. Dwight is on a fancy shopping spree.
我们以前介绍过La Tida吗？我不确定，但它们是蒸汽镇商场里的一家实体店。它们从商场开业那天一直开到2019年关门。La Tida卖什么？他们卖一些精致的小饰品和适合你家的精美送礼物品。德怀特正在进行一次疯狂的购物狂欢。
He certainly is. If he's shopping at La Tida, that should tell Precious Heirloom something. Before he leaves, he's going to go ahead and buy the wizard. Yeah, and Jim is like go ahead and buy the wizard. Yeah. And Jim is like, Dwight! I know. But he buys the wizard. This scene would have continued, Jenna. They would have left the store, and as they're leaving, Dwight smashes the wizard statue!
他当然是的。如果他在La Tida购物，那应该能说明“珍贵传家宝”店的一些问题。在他离开之前，他要继续买下那个巫师。是的，而吉姆就像是，去吧，买下那个巫师。是的，而吉姆就像是，德怀特！我知道。但他还是买下了那个巫师。这个场景本来会继续拍下去的，詹娜。他们会离开商店，就在他们离开时，德怀特砸碎了巫师雕像！
And Jim and Andy are like, what are you doing? And he pries the crystal out of the wizard's hand and he's like, you think I was here for this wizard? It's the crystal. Why do I remember that scene? I wasn't there when they shot it. Is it just like one of those moments when something was so funny to me at a table read that I've never forgotten it?
而吉姆和安迪就像是，你在干什么？他从巫师的手里撬出水晶，然后说，你以为我是为了这个巫师来的吗？是为了这块水晶。为什么我还记得那个场景？他们拍的时候我不在现场。这只是那种我在围读剧本时觉得太好笑以至于永远忘不掉的时刻吗？
Yeah. I remember that. Dwight had it out for the wizard and stole his crystal. I wish we would have kept that in. It's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. It's really funny. I guess we should talk about what happened between Michael and Toby after their session ended so abruptly with the double bird. Yeah. Toby just gives Michael the forums and is like,
是的。我记得那个。德怀特跟那个巫师杠上了，还偷了他的水晶。我真希望我们当时把那个保留下来。它在DVD的被删减片段里。真的很好笑。我想我们应该聊聊迈克尔和托比在他们以竖中指草草收场的咨询结束后发生了什么。是的。托比直接把表格扔给迈克尔并说，
you fill them out, say you completed the counseling, turn them in, I you completed the counseling, turn them in. I don't care. He's done with it. But I guess Michael accidentally checked off severe. He didn't read the forms. Yeah.
你把它填了，说你完成了咨询，交上去，我才不管呢。他受够了。但我想迈克尔不小心勾选了“严重”。他根本没看表格。是的。
He said that he was severe in all categories. And Gabe is like, wow, is this really how you feel about Michael after your counseling? And Toby's like, yeah, guess what? This is going to lead to more counseling. Yeah. Michael is so mad. But Toby has an idea. He says, you know what? Just forget it. Just get out your notebook. We'll just do some drawings. We'll just kill the time. Oh, I want you to know, I wish I had kept this prop.
他说他在所有类别上都属于严重。盖布就像是，哇，咨询过后你对迈克尔的看法真的是这样吗？托比就像是，对，你猜怎么着？这会导致更多的咨询。是的。迈克尔气坏了。但托比有个主意。他说，你知道吗？算了吧。拿你的笔记本出来。我们画点画吧。我们就是打发下时间。哦，我想让你们知道，我真希望我把这个道具留下来。
Me too. I wish I had it in a frame. Michael draws Dwight and Angela. Angela's taller than Dwight in the drawing. Mm-hmm. I wish I had this picture. I can't believe Toby is still trying to counsel Michael. He's like, wow, Angela's taller than Dwight.
我也是。我真希望把它装进框里。迈克尔画了德怀特和安吉拉。画里安吉拉比德怀特个子高。嗯哼。我真希望有这张画。我真不敢相信托比还在试图辅导迈克尔。他就像是，哇，安吉拉比德怀特高。
I wonder why you drew it that way. Yeah. Is that how it seems to you? Like Toby, Toby, stop. Oh my goodness. But the whole episode ends with a Ryan talking head. Yes, it does. It's one of the talking heads that would have been
我不知道你为什么要这么画。是的。在你看来是这样的吗？就像是，托比，托比，停下。噢天哪。但整集的结尾是一个瑞安的单采镜头。是的，确实如此。这是那些单采镜头之一，
this runner of everyone in the bullpen commenting on Michael's counseling. But here's the thing. Is it a talking head or is it a series of talking heads? We had a fan question from Joshua P. in Cincinnati and many others who would like to know, when Ryan lists off all of these various thoughts on therapy, and then at the end says, I don't know, just use the best one, were those scripted, or were they candy bag alts, and then they just stitched them together as one joke? I really appreciate this fan question, Angela, because remember in Niagara,
本该是办公区所有人对迈克尔咨询进行评论的串烧。但问题是，这是一个单采镜头，还是一系列单采镜头？我们收到了来自辛辛那提的约书亚·P.以及许多其他人的粉丝提问，他们想知道，当瑞安列举出所有这些关于治疗的各种想法，然后在最后说，“我不知道，就用最好的那个吧”，这些是剧本写好的，还是糖果袋里的备用台词，然后他们把它们缝合成一个笑话？我真的很感激这个粉丝提问，安吉拉，因为还记得在《尼亚加拉瀑布》里，
they had a bunch of candy bag alts for Dwight about his meat business? Yes, and they made them all one. Yes. By accident. Yes. And they didn't catch it until editing. So what happened here?
他们有一堆关于德怀特的肉类生意的糖果袋备用台词？是的，他们把它们做成了一个。是的。不小心弄的。是的。直到剪辑时他们才发现。所以这里发生了什么？
I want you to know, I went to the shooting draft and this is one complete talking head. It's not a bunch of candy bag alts. It's one talking head. BJ read it as scripted. And the last line of this talking head is, I don't know, just use the best one. Because Ryan is now savvy with the camera crew, right? He is. He knows they're going to edit. He's, you know, he's going through his suspenders and orange watch face and his glasses and his fedora hat.
我想让你们知道，我查了拍摄剧本，这是一个完整的单采镜头。它不是一堆糖果袋备用台词。这就是一个单采镜头。B·J是按剧本台词念的。这个单采镜头的最后一句话是，我不知道，就用最好的那个吧。因为瑞安现在对摄像团队很精明了，对吧？是的。他知道他们会剪辑。他，你知道的，他正摆弄着他的吊带、橙色手表盘、他的眼镜和他的呢帽。
He's savvy now. He is. I mean, listen, when we did the lip dub, he knew, I'm going to use this as an opportunity to advertise. That's right, for woof. Mm-hmm. Well, you guys, that was counseling. I so enjoyed rewatching this.
他现在精明了。他是。我是说，听着，当我们拍唇同步视频时，他知道，我要利用这个机会做广告。没错，为了“汪”。嗯哼。好吧，伙计们，那就是咨询。我非常享受重温这一集。
Big thank yous to Randy Cordray, Elise Myers, who you can find at Elise, E-L-Y-S-E, underscore, M-Y-E-R-S on Instagram. My friend Kate Walsh, who is going to be starring in a new Greg Garcia show called Sprung. Kate is just amazing. She's just in everything. She's already on Emily in Paris. I know. You can find her on Instagram, at Kate, K-A-T-E, W-A-L-S-H. And my dear friend Mika, who picked up the phone.
非常感谢兰迪·科德雷、爱丽丝·迈尔斯，你们可以在Instagram上通过@elise, E-L-Y-S-E, 键盘下划线, M-Y-E-R-S找到她。我的朋友凯特·沃尔什，她将在一部名为《跃起》的新格雷格·加西亚剧集中主演。凯特太棒了。她几乎无处不在。她已经在《艾米丽在巴黎》里演出了。我知道。你们可以在Instagram上通过@kate, K-A-T-E, W-A-L-S-H找到她。还有接电话的我的好朋友米卡。
Thank you, Michael. Thank you. You can find him on Instagram at Ultramike, U-L-T-R-A-M-I-K-E. I am really liking season seven. Let me just say that. Me too. These are good episodes. You guys, I jumped ahead the other day and I watched Andy's play and sex education.
谢谢你，迈克尔。谢谢你。你们可以在Instagram上通过@ultramike, U-L-T-R-A-M-I-K-E找到他。我真的很喜欢第七季。我只想说这个。我也是。这些都是好剧集。伙计们，我前几天跳集提前看安迪的戏剧和《性教育》了。
We've got lots to cover, lady. I can't wait. See you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to Stitcher Premium dot com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们有很多内容要讲，女士。我等不及了。下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜··费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版的《办公室女士》，请访问Stitcher Premium dot com。如需免费试用一个月的Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。